Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux !
Je suis ravi de vous accueillir
dans mon atelier
pour un nouveau format qui a vu le jour
au début de l'été et qui, plus que jamais,
est consacré à l'échange, la connaissance
et aussi l'aventure.
Dans "Bien reçu" - c'est
le nom de ce format -
j'ouvre cet espace
à des personnalités, connues ou pas,
pour partager avec elles leurs expériences,
leurs passions, leur curiosité,
leur goût du savoir
et aussi leurs projets.
Des femmes et des hommes, jeunes
ou moins jeunes, qui ont toutes et tous
une belle histoire à nous raconter.
Un message à nous faire passer.
Aujourd'hui, dans "Bien reçu" :
l'atelier se transforme en carré.
Nous mettons les voiles, cap
sur les mers du Sud.
Je suis très heureux d'accueillir
Lana Lenourry et Niels Dutrievoz,
deux étudiants membres de l'expédition
"Antarctique 2°".
Bonjour Jamy !
- Installez-vous !
Le grand public ne vous connaît pas,
je vais donc vous présenter Lana et Niels.
vous avez tous les deux 24 ans,
vous êtes étudiant à l'Ecole Normale
Supérieure de Paris-Saclay,
vous êtes de futurs chercheurs
et vous vous apprêtez
à embarquer à bord de la Louise,
une goélette de 19 mètres,
et à bord de laquelle vous allez rejoindre
la péninsule Antarctique.
Vous serez six étudiants à bord,
deux étudiantes,
quatre étudiants et vous étudiez tous
dans des disciplines différentes.
Lana, c'est quoi ta discipline?
Alors moi, je vais travailler
sur la biologie des populations
de manchots en Antarctique.
D'accord, Niels ?
et moi, je vais étudier la climatologie
et la glaciologie.
Avec vous, il y aura également Margot
Legal qui, elle,
est étudiante en sociologie.
Vous me dites si je dis des bêtises.
Il y aura Baptiste Arnaud.
Lui, c'est la microbiologie.
Clément Astruc-Delor, la biogéochimie.
Et Olivier Smith La chimie, c'est ça ?
Chimie des microplastiques,
exactement. Chimie des microplastiques.
Sans faute, presque.
Vous prenez quelque chose?
Un petit café, un thé ? Moi,
je partirai bien sur un café.
Parfait, 2 cafés.
Vous avez vu tout autour de nous?
Il y a pas mal de mugs.
Je vous invite à choisir le vôtre.
Il y en a une centaine.
Peut-être que vous trouverez
une thématique qui vous convient.
Voilà ! Ben oui, c'est évident.
Pour moi, c'est assez vite
vu. Le manchot, pour Lana
et moi, je vais choisir
celui-ci avec le vent.
Et oui, puisqu'on va parler
de météorologie, de climatologie
et de rivières atmosphériques.
Alors, quel est l'objectif
de cette expédition?
Notre objectif, c'est
de nous rendre en Antarctique.
Pour ça, on va partir à bord d'un voilier,
La Louise, que tu as présenté
pendant six mois.
On part de France, donc on traverse
l'Atlantique et l'objectif en Antarctique
et pendant la traversée de l'océan,
c'est d'étudier l'impact de l'homme
sur l'environnement.
Que ce soit la pollution ou le climat,
alors on va avoir
l'occasion de revenir sur sur tout ça.
Juste un mot sur le déroulement
de cet échange que vous avez pu remarquer.
Cet atelier, c'est
un peu la caverne d'Ali Baba.
La petite caméra et moi, on y stocke tout
un tas d'objets qu'on a glanés ici ou là
et on en a sélectionné certains
qu'on a disséminés dans cette pièce,
qui correspondent
aux différentes thématiques
et à ce que vous allez vivre
durant cette aventure.
Donc, ce que je vous propose,
et bien, c'est chacun à votre tour d'aller
chercher un objet
qui évoque votre expédition Lana
je t'invite à aller faire le premier
prélèvement dans cet atelier.
Alors moi, je veux
bien commencer par le bateau.
Voilà ce bateau.
Celui-ci, c'est une maquette.
C'est pas exactement celui que vous allez
à bord duquel vous allez naviguer.
Il y ressemble malgré tout
parce que c'est une goélette.
Et vous allez naviguer sur une goélette,
La Louise, un bateau de 19 mètres
qui est appareillé
pour aller dans des eaux polaires.
Exactement. Et en fait,
l'histoire de ce bateau,
c'est que c'est le capitaine Thierry
Dubois qui l'a construit.
Ce n'est pas n'importe qui.
Thierry Dubois, c'est un marin chevronné.
Il a été vainqueur de la Mini
Transat en 1993.
Il a fait le Vendée Globe
fois, deux fois et une fois
d'ailleurs, où il a chaviré.
Il a vécu quand même
des heures très difficiles,
donc il connaît un peu les eaux
dans lesquelles vous allez naviguer.
Il connaît les eaux,
il a l'habitude de naviguer.
L'équipage avec lequel
on part est un équipage
qu'il connaît bien puisqu'il
a l'habitude de naviguer avec eux.
Donc, je pense qu'on sera relativement
bien entouré pour cette expédition.
Il y en a qui sont navigateurs parmi vous
? Dans l'équipe ?
On est pas des navigateurs.
Il y en a qui ont
un peu d'expérience en voile,
mais rien de comparable
à ce qu'on va faire.
Et pour compléter ce que disait Lana,
je pense qu'aujourd'hui,
on est tellement la tête baissée
dans les préparations du voyage
qu'on ne s'est pas vraiment projeté
encore dans l'expédition.
Je ne sais pas quand est ce que ça va
arriver, le petit déclic de "On part
vraiment ! ", peut-être
quand on va mettre le pied dessus
et qu'on va larguer les amarres.
19 mètres à 9, c'est peu.
Au bout du compte, c'est peu, mais
le bateau est relativement bien agencé.
Il y a beaucoup de cloisons, donc en fait,
ça permettra à chacun d'avoir
pas son espace à proprement parler,
mais un peu d'intimité par moments.
Qu'est ce qu'on emmène quand on part
pendant six mois
et qu'on va vivre
sur un bateau de 19 mètres?
Le nécessaire, surtout qu'on va voir
d'une part, tous nos bagages
personnels, mais surtout,
surtout, le matériel scientifique
qui prend quand même pas mal de place
et tous les affaires de froid
pour l'Antarctique.
Vous emmenez des bouquins?
Oui, vraiment, des bouquins,
plein de bouquins.
Qu'est ce que vous emmenez
comme comme bouquins avec vous?
Il y a des bouquins pour étudier
parce qu'on est quand même
dans une année d'étude aussi,
donc des bouqins de travail.
Et personnellement,
j'ai pris également des bouquins
qui traitent de l'Antarctique,
des récits de grands explorateurs,
que ce soit les aventures de Shackleton
au niveau de la base de Vostok.
Des aventures qui sont incroyables,
donc j'ai pris les bouquins pour les lire
et relire pendant le trajet.
Lana ? Du coup, pour moi,
ça concerne aussi une expédition.
C'est celle de Charcot qui, en fait,
retrace exactement le parcours
qu'on va faire. Lui,
il est allé un peu plus loin que nous.
Il a dû hiverner,
Ce que j'espère qu'il nous arrivera pas.
Et je pense que ces
deux mois de transatlantique
seront une occasion rêvée
pour enfin lire ce livre. Allez !
Un deuxième objet, Niels.
Alors, je vais choisir le globe.
Ça va me permettre
de parler de l'itinéraire.
Vous partez d'où?
On va partir? En France,
Marseille, en Méditerranée.
Traverser la Méditerranée.
Passer Gibraltar.
On va descendre au niveau
des îles Canaries.
Ensuite, on va passer au Cap Vert.
Ensuite, on va traverser l'Atlantique
pour rejoindre le large du Brésil.
On va descendre le long du Brésil, de
l'Argentine pour arriver à la pointe Sud.
On va rester pendant deux semaines
au niveau de Punta Arenas, au Chili,
et ensuite on arrive
au niveau du nord de la péninsule.
On remonte par le même itinéraire
quasiment, pour retourner
en Bretagne, à Lorient.
Pourquoi avez-vous choisi
cette destination précisément?
La péninsule Antarctique
et pas un autre point sur ce continent.
C'est la seule région en Antarctique
où on peut se rendre en bateau
qui n'est pas un brise glace.
Troisième objet?
Est ce qu'on peut faire
un petit point sur peut être tout
ce qui est pédagogie dans notre projet?
En quoi ça consiste précisément?
La première chose qu'on a envie de
partager, c'est bien sûr cette expédition.
Et aussi, peut-être,
ce goût pour la science.
Parce que finalement, quand on est jeune,
on ne sait pas ce que c'est
que le métier de chercheur
ou on l'apprend tardivement et pourtant,
on le fait tous les jours à l'école.
On fait de la recherche dans la cour
de récré comme en classe.
Quand vous dites,
on essaie de les sensibiliser
au métier de chercheur, qu'est-ce que vous leur dites, vous, pour justement
leur donner peut-être envie de faire ce métier
ou de regarder le métier de chercheur
avec un autre regard?
On veut étudier, par exemple:
pour les plus jeunes,
l'évolution de la température
en fonction de la latitude.
On peut donc faire des hypothèses
quand on est dans la classe.
Ensuite, on monte un protocole
pour essayer de voir concrètement
comment on peut tester ça sur le terrain.
Nous, sur le bateau, ça va être
une expérience qu'on va pouvoir faire.
Les données leurs seront communiquées.
Ensuite, l'idée, c'est d'interpréter
et de conclure sur ces résultats.
La méthode scientifique, en quelque sorte?
Exactement. Aller un autre objet?
Niels, c'est à ton tour.
Je vais prendre la veste.
Vous serez dans l'hémisphère Sud
et que dans l'hémisphère Sud,
les saisons sont inversées.
Et donc, quand vous arriverez en décembre
dans cette région,
vous serez au début de l'été austral ?
Oui, complètement.
Ce sera décembre, janvier, février.
C'est la période estivale.
C'est la période durant
laquelle on peut s'y rendre.
Il fait moins froid.
Donc, il y a moins de banquise.
On peut se rendre en Antarctique,
Corée du festival.
C'est quand même
pas très chaud non plus, non ?
En température moyenne
on est à peu près 1°C et ça peut osciller
entre du -5°C et du 7°C.
Dans cette région, ça
peut descendre à -30°C à peu près l'hiver.
Ces températures froides,
vous vous y êtes préparés un petit peu ?
En fait, on s'est entraîné cet hiver
aux Arcs, déjà physiquement,
mais aussi à camper dans la neige. Donc
c'était une forme de préparation, un peu
aux températures froides qu'on va voir.
Alors en parlant de conditions
météo et d'équipement.
Il y a quelqu'un qui avait
un petit message à vous faire passer.
Venez avec moi. Alors
je ne vous présente pas ce personnage.
Je pense que vous le connaissez.
Voilà, bonjour, là, vous êtes bientôt
en route pour aller en Antarctique.
J'aimerais bien vous donner
d'autres conseils.
D'abord, vous allez
certainement pendant l'été.
Il fait 24/24h du soleil
et il fait pas vraiment
trop froid quand on reste
sur la bordure de l'Antarctique.
Quand on va au milieu, c'est sûr
que là, il commence à faire
beaucoup plus froid.
Il ne faut jamais aller
sans lunettes de soleil
parce qu'une fois qu'on a brûlé les yeux,
les gars, vous voyez plus rien.
Après, quand vous faites des efforts,
il faut surtout pas transpirer.
Mettez des couches de vêtements
sous vêtements en laine
avec du surcouches qui respirent.
Et quand vous êtes stationnaires
pour très longtemps.
Là, il faut mettre une veste en plumes.
Le troisième petit conseil que je vais
vous donner, c'est
de bien garder les pieds au sec
parce que quand on
transpire un tout petit peu
les chaussettes deviennent mouillées
et là, on commence à geler des pieds.
Si vous êtes comme moi
pendant une période de 130 jours,
tous les jours sur la glace
en ayant des chaussettes mouillées,
c'est sûr, qu'on va commencer
à avoir des problèmes.
Voilà 2- 3 petits conseils,
garder les lunettes,
des couches de vêtements
et des chaussettes secs.
On va bien suivre les conseils du boss.
Je pense qu'il faut bien l'écouter
parce que c'est des choses
qu'il connait bien.
Alors, c'est l'un de vos quatre parrains.
Il y a donc Mike Horn,
cet aventurier et explorateur.
Il y a Delphine Lannuzel,
qui est scientifique, chercheuse,
qui est spécialiste de l'Antarctique.
Il y a également une autre navigatrice,
quand je dis une autre
parce que je faisais référence à Thierry
Dubois, c'est Clarisse Crémer, qui
vient de participer
au dernier Vendée Globe et qui a réalisé
la meilleure performance féminine
sur le Vendée Globe depuis qu'il existe.
Et puis un quatrième parrain aussi,
qui est très heureux de vous accueillir
dans son atelier.
Bon, c'est sympa,
ce petit mot de Mike Horn.
Allez. Un autre objet, c'est
à qui le tour ? Lana.
Je pense que j'ai quelqu'un
qui me fait de l'oeil là-bas. Je crois.
Oui, il faut, il faut oser.
Je rappelle que les manchots, on ne
les trouve que dans l'hémisphère Sud.
Et c'est l'objet donc de ton étude.
Comme tu l'as dit, c'est un manchot.
Et ce n'est pas un pingouin.
C'est vrai que beaucoup de gens,
encore aujourd'hui,
confondent manchots et pingouins.
Les pingouins, c'est
dans l'hémisphère Nord.
OK, ce sont des oiseaux qui volent.
tandis que les manchots, c'est
dans l'hémisphère Sud.
Ils sont meilleurs nageurs que volatiles.
Exactement. Ils nagent
très bien, et d'ailleurs, tant mieux
puisque c'est là où ils pêchent.
C'est leur moyen de survie.
Et qu'est-ce que tu vas à étudier
précisément sur ces manchots?
Qu'est ce qui t'intéresse?
Moi, je vais particulièrement me focaliser
sur: comment ces manchots
se répartissent l'espace de nidification ?
J'ai vraiment envie de comprendre
comment un espace est plutôt occupé
par telle espèce ou telle espèce,
dans un même environnement,
et voir comment les changements à venir
pourraient modifier ces relations
entre les espèces.
C'est à dire que moi, j'ai
vu quelque chose qui m'intéresse là-haut.
Je peux le sortir. Oui vas-y.
C'est un drone. Donc,
par l'emploi de drones, je vais pouvoir
survoler les colonies
et voir la topographie
et le type de sol qu'ils occupent.
Allez, prochain objet Niels.
Alors, je vais choisir
le baromètre qui est là.
Donc, si tu as récupéré le baromètre,
c'est tout à fait logique puisque toi
tu bosses sur le climat
et notamment sur l'évolution
de la couche de neige
sur le continent Antarctique.
En fait, ce qu'on appelle le bilan
de masse de surface, c'est l'équilibre
entre tout ce qui arrive sur l'Antarctique
sous forme de neige ou de pluie
et tout ce qu'ils font.
Et en fait. Moi,
je vais étudier un processus qui contribue
largement à perturber cet équilibre
et donc c'est mes rivières atmosphériques.
J'avoue que c'est un terme
que j'ai rarement entendu.
Je pense que le public
est un peu comme moi.
Qu'est ce qu'une rivière atmosphérique?
Une rivière atmosphérique, c'est
une image qui désigne un courant aérien,
une sorte de chenal atmosphérique qui
transporte de l'humidité et de la chaleur.
Pour former une rivière
il faut deux formations.
Il faut déjà un anticyclone.
Donc, c'est ce qu'on entend à la météo.
C'est associé au beau temps,
une zone de haute pression
et il faut une dépression, donc, ce qui
est souvent associé à du mauvais temps.
Si la dépression vient heurter
cet anticyclone,
les deux formations dont je parle
ont des sens de rotation différente.
Et en fait, entre ces deux formations,
on va avoir un phénomène de rivière comme
une sorte de tapis roulant d'humidité
qui va être projeté vers l'Antarctique.
Et est-ce que ça veut dire
que les changements climatiques
qui s'opèrent en ce moment pourraient
avoir une incidence
sur ces rivières atmosphériques?
En fait, c'est vraiment
l'objet de mon étude.
C'est de voir comment,
dans le contexte actuel,
quelles évolutions
on a sur l'intensité des rivières
et sur leur fréquence,
ce qui impacte largement
le bilan de masse
de surface de l'Antarctique.
Et ça peut contribuer à déstabiliser ce
qu'on appelle des plateformes glaciaires.
Et ensuite, à terme,
ça peut contribuer à augmenter
le village des icebergs
et donc à augmenter le niveau des eaux.
Ce qu'il faut bien comprendre,
c'est que ce continent antarctique,
c'est vrai que on a du mal
à s'en faire une image.
Je crois qu'en moyenne, c'est
1600 mètres de glace.
C'est de la roche, c'est ça.
Et ça peut aller jusqu'à
3000, 4000 mètres d'épaisseur
au niveau du centre de l'Antarctique.
En fait, 70% de l'eau douce présente
sur Terre est au niveau de l'Antarctique.
Pour avoir un ordre de grandeur
du volume de glace que ça représente,
si jamais l'Antarctique
venait à fondre intégralement,
ça représenterait une élévation
du niveau moyen des océans de 57 mètres.
Je vais continuer du coup
dans les projets scientifiques.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'il vous évoque?
C'est des petites particules de plastique
et ça représente pas mal
le projet d'Olivier qui consiste à étudier
les microplastiques.
Donc, communément, ce qu'on
appelle microplastiques, c'est des petites
particules de plastique inférieures
à 5 mm et Olivier va les étudier
d'une part dans l'eau,
pendant toute la traversée de l'Atlantique,
et dans l'océan Austral
mais aussi dans la neige
et dans les sédiments autour des colonies.
Ça, c'est pour les microplastiques.
Il y a un autre élément qui va être
étudié, c'est le phytoplancton.
Exactement.
Et ça, c'est le projet de Baptiste
et de Clément, donc batisse
et de la microbiologie
et clément de la biogéochimiques.
Et ça correspond à l'étude
des micro-organismes
et de leur présence dans l'océan.
Donc, l'intérêt de cette étude,
c'est qu'aujourd'hui, 25% du CO2
émis par l'homme est absorbé par l'océan.
Pour se développer,
ces micro-organismes ont besoin
d'un élément qu'on appelle l'élément fer.
Et Clément va regarder dans l'eau,
justement, la présence ou l'absence
de cet élément fer qui est essentiel
au développement des micro-organismes.
Baptiste, quant à lui, va regarder
dans les micro-organismes,
l'ADN et l'ARN des micro-organismes,
les gènes qui sont exprimés
pour utiliser cet élément fer.
Allez, le dernier objet c'est une image, c'est
le drapeau qui se trouve
juste derrière nous.
Alors, c'est le drapeau de la Slovénie.
Et en fait, c'est le dernier pays
qui a signé le traité sur l'Antarctique
ou le traité de Washington, qui était
initialement signé en 1959.
En fait, l'Antarctique, c'est un continent
unique pour de nombreuses raisons,
mais c'est un continent
qui n'appartient à personne,
mais qui est revendiqué
par pas mal de monde.
Donc, il a été découvert en 1819
et depuis, il y a de nombreux pays
qui ont participé à son exploration
et donc qui revendiquent
des portions du territoire.
Et puis, c'est l'occasion aussi de dire
que ce continent qu'on a du mal à mesurer
quand on regarde une carte
ou quand on regarde un globe, c'est
quand même très, très vaste puisque c'est
14 millions de kilomètres carrés.
C'est 1,4 fois l'Europe ou 25 fois
la France à peu près.
Voilà donc. Donc, c'est immense.
Cet immense territoire
aujourd'hui n'appartient à personne,
ou plutôt appartient à tout le monde.
Mais il est réservé
donc à la recherche, à la science et
à la biodiversité.
C'est ça. Et en fait,
tous les pays qui font de la science
là-bas doivent coopérer dans un espace
assez restreint.
Et ça, c'est l'étude de Margaux,
qui est sociologue et qui va travailler
sur la collaboration entre les différents
pays présents sur zone.
Et donc, en fait,
on a plusieurs corps de métier
qui interagissent
et qui coopèrent ou pas sur ce territoire.
Et c'est l'objet d'études de Margaux.
Merci Lana, merci Niels.
On va vous laisser achever
votre préparation d'ici quelques jours.
Vous allez lever l'ancre.
Et puis, pour tous ceux qui veulent
vous suivre durant votre périple.
C'est possible sur les réseaux sociaux
et puis via votre site Internet.
Oui, c'est ça le site, c'est
J2D pour l'association "Juste 2° J2D.org "
et on est sur tous les réseaux, donc
Facebook, Instagram, Twitter et LinkedIn.
Eh bien, bon vent.
Bonne collecte d'informations.
Pensez à bien vous couvrir.
Et puis, évidemment, vous nous donnerez
de vos nouvelles durant votre périple.
Puis j'espère bien
vous accueillir ici au même endroit
d'ici quelques mois, à votre retour,
pour que vous nous racontiez
comment ça s'est passé.
Voilà à très bientôt.
Et bon vent. Merci beaucoup.